you are here a film on a site was destroyed indeed deserved the russian army was arrested next to several other cities of the massacres were perpetrated or by plane the first traces of skiing which are war crimes on which we we are cooperating very strongly, moreover, I would like to thank all the expert gendarmes and French magistrates who were deployed and for the first few days alongside experts with this image of a devastated city of both a heroic void since it is here that the among other things that discreet zero the Ukrainians you stopped the Russian army which descended on kyiv so you have to imagine the heroism of the army but also of the Ukrainian population on green leaves is with him I have always been constant the France is alongside Ukraine on June 1 and President 1 and what he himself always wanted to discuss with President Putin today Ukraine must be able to resist and win me over and therefore no  we
are at their side two
ukrainians of ukrainians without ambiguity